من جهته قال وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
تمار بن جفير ان اي صفقه غير شرعيه ستؤدي
الى حل الحكومه حسب تعبيره ل المزيد من
القراءه معنا من حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب
المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي طبعا هذا
الموقف لاتمر بن جفير سيد جبارين هو في
ذات الاطار الذي يتحرك فيه اليمين المتطرف
لعرقله اي صفقه محتمله لكن على الرغم من
ذلك هناك ما يمكن ان نصفه بالانطباعات
الايجابيه داخل مجلس الحرب بخصوص هذه
الصفقه كيف يبدو الموقف الاسرائيلي
بخصوصها حتى الان كما
تتابعوا نعم تحياتي ومساء الخير يعني
بطبيعه الحال ولكين تضع الامور في سياقها
بشكل اكبر يجب ان نتذكر ان لطالما وان
كانت القرارات تتخذ في الغرف المغلقه وبن
يمين تنياه لديه الضلع الاكبر والكم
الاكبر لماذا لا يريد التقدم في داخل هذه
صفقات ولكن هنالك امرين اثنان يجب ان
ناخذه ما بعين الاعتبار بالنسبه لنتنياهو
في المقام الاول يجب ان نتذكر انه يعني
بنيامين تنهو يدير كل هذه الحرب ما بين ال
العلاقات العامه ما بين اداره العلاقات
العامه وما بين اداره الازمات وتحديدا هذه
المره يمكن القول ان بنيامين نتنياهو ادار
جلسه الكابينت ضمن منظومه اداره الاز
الازمات لم يكن هنالك الكثير من التسريبات
لم يكن هنالك الكثير من الاشاعات حتى بهذا
الخصوص وهذا ربما يدل على مدى الضغط
المتواجد فيه بنيامين نتنياهو وا يعني كم
كم الضغط من الطرف الاخر بالمناسبه لان
الضغط من الطرف اليميني ومنهم عن يمينه
واضح جدا ولكن في الطرف الاخر هنالك
تراكميه في المشهد ولهذا السبب على ما
يبدو انه رضخ الى هذه المنطلق على ان يجد
استراتيجيه خروج من هذه الصدقه او من هذه
الهدنه في مرحله معينه لان هذا الامر
الوحيد الذي يضمن لبنم نتنياهو الكرسي هذا
في السياق الاول وكذلك في السياق الاخر
يجب ان نخذ بعين الاعتبار
بان اتمر بينبر يتعامل بقوالب ايديولوجيه
غير قابله للكسر باي شكل من الاشكال على
القيض من ذلك بنيامين نتنياهو يتعامل
بقوالب استراتيجيه التي يمكن كسرها عندما
يكون مازو ما ويكون موجود في دائره الخطر
هو قام بذلك في اكثر من موقف بامور عرضت
ايديولوجي ولكنها تتوافق مع الا المتطلبات
الاستراتيجيه كالذهاب على سبيل المثال في
اتفاق الخليل انذاك في عام
97 صفقه جل عادش اللي تحديدا في هذا
السياق قام بها وعلى انها على الرغم انها
يعني تناقد كل مفهومه ل مفهوم تبادل
الاسرى وما الى ذلك وبالتالي واضح جدا انه
في هذه المرحله مازوم ايه بشكل كبير بل
على عكس من ذلك يمكن حتى قراءه ان المؤتمر
الضوء الاخضر الذي كان للمؤتمر قبل يومين
مؤتمر الاستيطان والاحتلال
بطبيعه الحال هو كان نوع من تنفيذ ذلك
اليمين وكانه اعطى ذلك اليمين نوع من
الهديه ليلهو بها وللتقدم قدما هذا
بالقراءه الاولى كذلك نقطه مهمه جدا كما
قلنا لم يكن هنالك الكثير من التسريبات
لكن كان هنالك اشاعات التي كانت تخدم رؤيه
بنيامين نتنياهو في هذا السياق الامر
الاول هو
النفي يعني جزئيه الارقام كان هنالك تناول
كثير للارقام والمعطيات وكم سوف يتم تحرير
من الاصر وما الى ذلك هذا الامر تم نفيه
في اكثر من موضع وتم التلاعب حتى
بالمعطيات بل حتى ان السياق الاخير ربما
الذي اتى على لسان جهات مقرمه بنتنياهو
بانها مستعده ان تدفع الثمن الكبير لاحظ
مستعده ان تدفع الثمن الكبير لكن ليس في
ذات الارقام التي يتم تسريبها اي هنالك
نوع من تاطير ذلك واستيعاب الطرف الاخر
الطرف اليمين وجزئيه كذلك مهمه جدا تسيب
كذلك كان مهم جدا ايه لذوي الاسرى بالذات
انه لم يكن يستطيع التلاعب بالمعطيات
كثيرا تم تسيب وكان حماس لن تستطيع ان
تقبل بهذه الشروط ايه او بشكل اضق تماطل
في هذه الشرو طبعا وانت تتحدث سيد ايهاب
جبارين نشير الى هذا البيان الجديد للجيش
الاسرائيلي والذي
نقرا بعض تفاصيله على شاشتنا في الخبر
العاجل الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول ان
2777 ضابطا وجنديا اصيبوا منذ بدايه الحرب
11 و83 منهم اصيبوا منذ بدء الهجوم البري
هذا اذا في احدث احصاء يقدمه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن الاصابات في صفوف ضباطه
وجنوده منذ بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه وكذلك لمن اصيبوا منذ بدايه الهجوم
البري ويقول ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
26 عسكريا اصيبوا في معارك قطاع غزه خلال
الساعات ال
2 الماضيه اذا خسائر الجيش الاسرائيلي في
زياده يوميا يسقط ضباط وجنود في هذه
المعارك المستمره والكلف كلفه هذه الحرب
تزيد وتحرج نتنياهو الان امام هذه
المعطيات وضغوط الاهالي اهالي الاسرى هل
سيذهب نتنياهو الى هذه الصفقه مع كل
الشروط التي وضعتها حماس قرانا وسمعنا
بيان اسماعيل الهنيه الذي يؤكد فيه دائما
على اولويات الذهاب الى اي صفقه وهي وقف
العدوان والانسحاب من قطاع غزه وكل تلك
الاولويات التي يشير اليها هل سيقبل
نتنياهو
بذلك طبعا اتفاقيه الاطار ربما التي لن
يشعر بها بنيمين نتنياهو بالحرج كثيرا
امام اليمين لانه في نهايه المطاف القرار
يعني وان كان بنيمين نتنياهو هو الواجهه
لكن القرار هو الضغوطات التي ممكن ان
تتشكل من اليمين
فبالتالي اتفاقيه الاط الاطار عفوا تضمن
لبن من نتنياهو نقطه مخرج معينه بمفهوم
كهذا او كاخر او نقطه بشكل اضق هي لا تضمن
له ولكنها نقطه التي يمكن ان يستغلها
بينيامين نتنياهو لفض الهدنه في لحظه شعر
بها بالح بالحرج او بالضيق
امام الشارع اليميني تحديدا هذا من جهه
عندما نتحدث عن مراحل عندما نتحدث عن امور
احن راينا كيف تعامل نتنياهو مع الصفقه
الاولى التي لطالما عرضها لكن عندما وصل
اليها وصف بالمقدس وفي اليوم الثامن فضها
لانها في نهايه المطاف لم تخدمه انتخابيا
الشع الاسرائيلي لم لم ولن يغفر لبنيامين
نتنياهو هذا بات واضح فبالتالي هذا المخرج
الاول كذلك نقطه مهمه جدا يجب ان ناخذها
بعين الاعتبار هو ان نتنياهو يبحث في هذه
الايام بشكل جدي مسارات اخرى لضمان قاعده
لحكومته اي احزاب اخرى ممكن ان تنضم
وطالما عاكس لابيد وا ليبرمان في وزارات
معينه التي يمكنهم ان ينضموا اليها فواضح
جدا ان هذا السيناريو كذلك هو ياخذه على
محمل الجاد لكي يحاول ان يعني يعطي عمرا
لحكومته طبعا هذا المطلب او السيناريو
يمكن ان يكون بعيدا نوعا ما عن التحقيق
ولهذا السبب المخرج الثالث الذي يقوم
ببحثه بنيامين نتنياهو واذا تم فض هذه
الحكومه في ضربه استباقيه لم يتوقعها هو
ان يكون هنالك احزاب يسمى باحزاب المسبار
الذي التي تضمن له المقاعد التي هربت من
الليكود ان ان يضمنه عبر احزاب اخرى اي
تعطيه شبكه امان ايهاب جبارين الكاتبه
المختصه في الشان الاسرائيلي من حيفا شكرا
جزيلا لك